hey youtubers is Charlie so I finally
got to see x-men Days of Future past so
I wanted to do a review of the movie and
because it changes the x-men universe in
such an interesting way I'm gonna do a
breakdown of the new timeline as well as
the post-credits scene that's right if
you go see the movie remember to stay
through all the credits if you're
finding me for the first time I'm gonna
be doing a bunch more big movie reviews
just because so many big things are
coming this summer like guardians of the
galaxy Planet of the Apes How to Train
Your Dragon 2 be sure to subscribe to
get everything and if there's a movie
that you really want me to do a video
for it just let me know in the comments
so because most of you probably have not
seen the movie yet I'm gonna start with
a non-spoilery review and then I'll go
into spoilers where I talk about my top
5 moments as well as the post credits
scene in the new timeline so don't worry
there will be a warning for spoilers
though right off the bat I really love
the movie it's a very different type of
superhero movie from Winter Soldier
which came just a little while ago I
thought of it as being like a
revisionist history political thriller
that also had superheroes in it like
they could have made this movie without
any superheroes or time travel and it
still would have been a really
interesting story which is one of the
reasons why I think that they asked
Bryan Singer to return to direct the
movie because he does thrillers really
well and he does ensemble films really
well and there are a ton of characters
in this movie one of the most notable
differences between this movie and say
that Marvel films is that the cast is so
much bigger at least the main cast they
have so many characters it takes a lot
of work just to make sure you don't
forget what the actual story is and
Bryan Singer did a really good job of
maintaining the through line of the
x-men trying to change the past you know
the essential the a story so I really
like the way they shot the movie they
made it look very very different in the
future than they did in the past
so it typically looks like a normal film
in the future you know digital cameras
special effects but whenever they go
into the past they use this awesome real
old newsreel footage look so it looks
like you're actually watching films that
were filmed in the 70s even though it
didn't lean too hard on you know big
special effects there were some really
big action set pieces that were really
cool they spoiled most of them in the
trailers like you would expect so there
weren't a lot of surprises I did like
that they didn't go crazy with
explaining all the new characters powers
like Quicksilver let's talk about the
characters for a second because that's
actually where the movie really really
shines yes it was fun seeing the
original x-men on screen with the first
class versions
and Patrick Stewart totally gets his
awesome professor Eck's speechifying
moments but my favorite performances
were from Evan Peters as Quicksilver and
Hugh Jackman really though Evan Peters
was definitely the most fun person to
watch after this movie though it feels
like the most visible actors in the
franchise are gonna be Jennifer Lawrence
and Hugh Jackman combined them together
and you basically have what Robert
Downey jr. is for Marvel you know this
big giant face that they can market to
everyone
Hugh Jackman was originally gonna retire
from the role of Wolverine after this
movie but he's totally backtracked since
then and he's planning on doing another
Wolverine spin-off which is probably to
be like an old man Logan film and the
next x-men sequel which is gonna be
x-men apocalypse so he's gonna continue
to be the face of the x-men franchise
for a long time but now it's time to
talk about my top five favorite moments
so there will be spoilers so careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the movie
yet but here we go number 5 the new
post-apocalyptic future it's always fun
to see the end point you know like
skipping ahead to the last page in a
book if you watch the 90s x-men cartoons
they did an x-band Age of Apocalypse
storyline with some of the new
characters that we see in the movie like
Bishop for instance Days of Future past
is a whole different storyline from the
comics from the Age of Apocalypse but
visually the world of the future looks
very similar everything just ends up in
a pile of rubble and bodies it was a lot
of fun to see all that future tech - I
kind of wonder what was powering the new
Quint jet like a small fusion reactor or
something like that the Sentinels were
really cool - if you didn't catch it
they were mimicking Mystique's powers to
adapt to different mutants powers that's
why they could use fire against Bobby or
ice against Sun SPOT a lot of the
Sentinels did kill people with you know
regular physical attacks but I feel like
the most popular kill shot was Cyclops I
beam number 4 the world of the 70s
one of my favorite things about the
movie was just the way they made
everything look the visual style like
everyone had Wolverines sideburns you
know totally kidding but if you've heard
stories about how New York City turned
into a dump during the 70s and 80s
that's kind of what I thought when they
showed the x-men in the past for the
first time it's like after the 60s in
that first class movie the Vietnam War
happened and everything just went to
hell all the main characters are just in
awful places psychologically mystique
has become this disillusioned and
person and it seems like everyone just
hates themselves that's why the biggest
chunk of the movie is that call to
action all those characters digging
themselves out of their own graves
number three old Logan in the 70s
if it wasn't clear when he goes back in
time his body has not been infused with
adamantium yet and he hasn't met Stryker
which is why he freaks out whenever he
sees young striker for the first time
Hugh Jackman really became the face of
this movie even if the plot revolves
around Jennifer Lawrence but I feel like
they weaved him in and just kind of a
funny way as if he's forgotten how awful
the 70s are in that whole time remember
he's been alive longer than any other
x-man they did add just the right amount
of Logan jokes you know using his
healing factor for comedy and him just
putting up with dumb from the 70s
of all the characters he really is one
of the few who can say they've heard
every single joke that's ever been told
and seen everything there is to see so
logically he should be the least
surprised by everything I love that the
character is such a loner but they give
him the burden of doing this call to
action you know bringing all these
characters together even though Patrick
Stewart does give him a little bit of
help and the great thing is that as much
as they changed the timeline at the end
of the movie it's still the same old
Logan grumpy old Logan I would not have
him any other way
number 2 Jennifer Lawrence as mystique
there's a whole lot going on with
Jennifer Lawrence in the x-men movies
and in real life right now she's just
blowing up as older cast members start
to get older she's probably going to
become the face of the franchise like
the mega star that they used to market
it though as long as she keeps doing
x-men movies she'll continue to be one
of the central characters in the plot
that is the good thing about this is not
only is Jennifer Lawrence a really
amazing actress he's also this loner
character of mystique just like Logan so
she can always align herself with new
villains that come along like the new
villain and Age of Apocalypse I'll talk
about that more in a second but overall
I think she had a stronger performance
in the movie than James McAvoy or
Michael Fassbender really a lot of those
other characters took a backseat to her
and Logan in this movie and I thought it
totally worked
and my number one moment the new changed
timeline so many things to say about
this what happened is is they basically
negated the events of Wolverine Origins
and x3 that Brett Ratner movie which I'm
so happy about they didn't throw away
any of Bryan Singer's x-men movies the
first two so everyone
back but I think all the future sequels
will mostly just be the new first-class
cast members you know Jennifer Lawrence
Michael Fassbender James McAvoy the
interesting thing about changing the
past though is that a lot of things
still probably played out the same way
but I think future sequels will address
those gaps in time but now it's your
turn let me know in the comments below
what was your favorite moment you know
was it one of the big action set pieces
or was it some of the new characters I
know I didn't really talk about the big
action set piece you know the magneto
one but as cool as it was they basically
spoiled it in the trailer so it wasn't
really a WTF surprise moment
post-credits scene time as I expected it
was all about teasing the next x-men
sequel x-men apocalypse that's coming in
a couple years
probably 2017 maybe late 2016 depends on
whenever they get started even though
the main villain is obviously going to
be apocalypse we could see mr. sinister
or a lot of other evil mutants they
could always bring along if you want to
learn a lot more about apocalypse I'm
obviously going to be doing more bonus
videos about him but you should also
watch the cartoon series from the 90s
that's on Netflix and read the Age of
Apocalypse comic book essentially he's
been living in the x-men world for
thousands of years so presumably the
movie the x-men movie will explain why
we haven't seen him in any of the movies
yet just because he's so powerful you
know why wouldn't he be around I totally
love that they showed him building the
Great Pyramids what did I say about
x-men being revisionist history films if
it wasn't clear the scene was in ancient
Egypt
I think the pyramid he was building was
the Great Pyramid of Giza which was
constructed about 2560 BC so that gives
you an idea for how old he is I think
essentially he was born around 3000 BC
so he's basically immortal much more so
than Wolverine Wolverine isn't really a
mortal he just heals himself constantly
so he just ages very very slowly so I
will be talking about apocalypse in a
much more bonus videos in the future be
sure to subscribe to get everything
there's also a couple more bonus videos
I'm working on this weekend there's no
Game of Thrones but I will have a bonus
video and there's some cool Doctor Who
stuff happening also thank you so much
for your patience
I'm travelling right now so I have like
really awful Wi-Fi in my old crummy
laptop so everything is just really
really slow right now click here to get
my breakdown of the gardens of the
galaxies trailer and click here to learn
all about arrow season 3 and the new
flash TV show thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow high fives